opa erzählt dass sie lebendig vergraben
wurde und auch schlacht mit mir reden
kann
parallel welt die verschwörungs
geschichte der schweiz sondern ist über
den abscheulichen ritual kinder
missbrauchen wo das glaubt der oberarzt
für psychiatrische klinik littenheid was
wir auch so aus dem dritten reich als
foltermethoden in den
konzentrationslagern kann mit alles dort
angewendet ddr kollmann therapiert opfer
sexuellen missbrauchs von hand mit genau
der inhalt noch ausgaben einander sagen
weil man besorgt therapiekosten
zum opfer der obere als die schmidts ihm
glauben rituelle missbrauchen ich habe
keinerlei zweifel dass es das thema
wirklich gibt einige berichtet sogar vor
menschlicher wesen gefällt werden die
sogenannte diese aktivitäten tat stöhr
ich wohl vom tag besser bewusst
verursacht
die horror streifen die für schwierige
geschichte psychiatrische therapie
sitzige alter schule wie der polizei und
der politik
dass er keine passieren dass kleine zu
alles angefangen mit der e mail
geschrieben hat dass sie sich hinter
aktuell und sexuell missbraucht wird
sich kreuze dass die von aaa oder salat
also sie hätten übergriff erlebt aber
die geschichte zu die ist so wahnsinnig
sie dass ich das nicht auch eine glaube
es schlimmeres die frauen wie das made
you had gebe mir gesagt dass ich einen
verein der wie kohl verhält dass sie das
quasi für die tolle und der verein
kanadas ist ein spitzenverein der
karstadt für care about us und die
glaube tatsächlich dass es so zirkel
gibt satanisten zettel wovon die
betreiber sind wo
manche missbrauchen
der für ein kader macht allmend ein
informationsseminar wir sind offiziell
als journalistin von messerer veraltet
wo sich für das thema rituelle gewalt
interessiert
mich ein klarer sieg im juni 2008
bekannt ich bin ich zum ersten mal an
den vorveranstaltungen tun weil ich
wähle wisse was er direkt evans
geschichte alles
sieht ein wenig skeptisch aber sie waren
mich davon überzeugen dass ihre
geschichte stimmt der präsident vom
verein geht alles bereitwillig auskunft
das ist eine zahlt das ist richtig gehen
die
parallelwelt wo professionell
organisiert und geschützt ist und da war
mir die informieren und aufklären
die kann ich ganz viel betroffenen
überleben die dann muss es ja um somit
das gibt viel und das ist mittelschiff
bisher sollte mich story mit einer
mutter freimuth und die hockenheimer
schlüsselstellen einer die liga
interesse dass das offiziell bekannt
wird schwedischen schutz für die was
passiert ein ritual es wird gefoult und
macht bis zum tod und den oft als
betrunken und das und
es geht nicht um eine sensation sondern
einfach realität gemacht wird ich das
gefühl das ganze ist eine klassische
verschwörung celik aber wenn ich der
herr damit direkt mit dem konfrontiert
würdest du und auch öffentlichkeit mehr
erfahren was sie denn auch vor gott noch
schlimmer er will die mich zum täter
machen es gibt meiner truppe mit oder
vor der andere sieht man das so nennen
die grenzen der imster noch ohne im
nachgang irgendwelche optik geschrieben
oder die formieren
[Musik]
dem tagesseminar wie die schwierige
geschichte wieder gehen lassen xandros
als weiterbildung es sind lehrer
psychologen und sozialpädagogen
ich immer wieder legt also einerseits
mit missbrauchsopfern
aber jetzt auditore das erlebt haben
betroffenen
für betroffene sexualisierter
nationale
schrecklich dass die schwierigste celik
winterthurer zu therapeuten
settings wo das einfach nicht verloren
hat
[Musik]
jetzt sind offenbar zu der rhythmus ist
gründerin von dem verein karo märz gab
vorhaben das sie sind und eine seminare
zeigen sie mir der film
parallelwelten in dem film mit haxe
bewohner und er war das auto nicht
jetzt sagen wir mal mit der gründerin
über den film reden der grüne sind für
mich
dies war unglaublich klingen aber auch
noch in 21 jahren dort werden menschen
auf grausame art missbrauchen dies
geschieht im geheimen zirkeln und
organisationen und das mitten in unserer
gesellschaft
das verstand
ich liebe wichtig und das sind die
betroffenen überredet und daneben der
leiter von kinderschutz vor die stapo
zürich der dass sie gegen chemie zu
wählen
tja
ja
auch das muss jetzt mal einen
präzedenzfall
die polizei musste
nicht einfach sexuelle passieren dass
der arbeit
ist mir bestätigt oder ich bin
ja mit platz acht
[Musik]
jetzt sehen wir auf dem weg zur
stadtpolizei zürich und zwar zum thomas
werner steht der abteile kinderschutz
ein termin mit ihm zwei ist schwierig
sie also die eltern haben nie zeit hatte
druck mache und sage dass ich für
schwierig videos haben mit dem titel
parallelwelten und das ist die luft
riecht und dass das für mich sehr
verstörende gerät sie aber er hat schon
mehrere hippies beharrt dass es aber in
der schweiz an schienen
satanistische rituelle übergriff gibt
finder und wir sind natürlich jetzt
nicht sich das tatsächlich so also gibt
es das gibt s doch anzeige für das
und sind vor dem auto gehört ja also
gehört einerseits verstärkt aus oder wo
es gibt für mich leider kein grund zur
unvermutet wie sodass es nicht sollten
sie auf großen reifen und auch schon
alte knacker und gelben trikot
persönlich davon aus dass es das
tatsächlich gibt es ist so dass mehrere
tv wo ist gemeldet wird die meldung
wonach und nein wir selbstverständlich
sehr ernst da kam mir alles ist es eher
mit herzblut die dass man so viel
scheint klar es ist tatsächlich aber so
dass man die babys sanieren können
erbringen dass es tatsächlich wieder
eine gemeldete delikte von so einem fall
handelte das wirklich also im inneren
waren einige wird sagt ist mir im garten
glauben ich will
meine menschen so viel fall erlaubt wo
haarsträubend sind also das schlimmste
um sicher vorstellen der wüste oder im
bereich geschafft für den kinderschutz
es gibt noch viel schlimmer die gemeinde
hockenheim möglich extrem detailliert
mit staatsanwaltschaft zusammen mit halt
auf zwangsmaßnahmen auf den
zwangsmaßnahmen gericht bei weniger tote
sind sehr tief stand und zu halten
schlussendlich das strafverfahren 500
verurteilung der musiker wir sind
erschrocken und musik mit dem film
parallelwelten also schon dank dass gott
wieder das darf nicht mehr mit der
realität zu ich habe mir den film mir
ist nur wichtig sie will aber mir auch
schon einmal gegenüber vor hinter und
mir auch schon dieser fall
ermittelt hand und
fuß und hand aber sehr viel
mittel und niedrig gesteckt hat ist mir
aber wichtig zum der gruppierung
aufzeigen wie sie schwierigkeiten sehen
das problem sind und was funktioniert
und was nicht funktioniert es geht also
lud wo sadistische rituelle missbrauch
zum arzt bringen und dem gitarristen
wieder thomas werne wurde eine art zeige
auch noch geld
gehörte
ich wollte meine gedanken mit der boom
spiegler der markovic
sozialwissenschaftler mit spezialgebiet
verspüre ich erzähle und fake news
dimension also meine brust vorgang ganz
das was mir auf der spur sind was hätte
das budget ausgelöst und was hat das mit
dir gemacht es hat mich schockiert
als zehn wahrscheinlich muss ein schnell
kinder sind wurden oder weil der
missbrauch das weiß man aber das ist die
systematische
verschwörungs
negativ gibt es gibt eine satanische
missbrauch verhindert da haben wir
einiges glück dass ich mit dieser
technik ist es aber leider nicht es ist
ja nicht ganz mein schlecht dass man die
so dynamik von innere das weiß man aus
der forschung die alle hinter auf harnik
der für egal ob jung alt 10 krieg rovers
mal frau während andere und das stück
wie zufall
führungslos ist dass dort sei es gilt
ich würde sagen als definitiv am rechten
fleck ich glaube glaubt wirklich dass
wir die schwerste gesetz würde ich ihn
vor den netzwerks gebucht werden ganz
offensichtlich hatten total kognitive
tun und ich glaube besondere
verantwortungsvolle position dürfte sich
entspannung für propaganda und mein buch
finde das ist propaganda und ansitz
müssten einfach die fähigkeit zum
kritischen denken zum selbst
reflektieren können
schlimm wird es dann wenn manche
beeinflusst leider mit der geschichte
dann gehts familiendrama
kindertag ich glaube sie sexuell
missbraucht wurde und wo denn der
kontakt zu ihren eltern abbrechen oder
der kontakt zu den eltern ab wochen wird
und das ist hochdramatisch und darum
wollen wir jetzt noch hey sagt seine
frau hat nämlich dass
sie auf ein gutes
historische antworten
und sie stellen die therapie kann sich
auf verschiedene
toxischen liter heizöl sich in
münsterlingen sie eigentlich immer auf
die drama stationen und dänischen
stauferzeit also minimal zeigt wege
missbrauch
mz und diese sind den e mails für wo sie
ihren damaligen therapeuten geschickt
hätte die innenstadt aber das meer zum
beispiel spezielle vom friedhof den
kindle opfer das mandat enthält und
töpfer packen und noch einer
röthlein und da weist sein und war so
ganz schlimme sache und das tut auch
noch
genau also ich lohmar und sagt man sie
intern der regen aufhört dass man im
wahlduell macht und dass der klinker
gesicht mit umbringen
und sie schreibt genau mein gott tasche
furchtbare zeit braucht das verfahren
ist den weg stellt beachten wenn man das
ist alles einfach die therapie erkennt
wir verkohlt war dafür gold vater das
bleibt ja nehmen man glaubte das
verrückte glaubt dass das tatsächlich
passiert ist geht davon aus dass es
einfach war nämlich verdiene der tochter
ist dass sie so vielleicht zum ausdruck
bringt wie sie sich fühlt nein
dann hätte der kreis irgendwann tisch im
mathäser auch noch die steaks für für
gegner weiß nicht wirklich passiert ist
man jetzt sein können bewiesen und das
ist denn es wurde da wird gezeigt und
auch in der verwandtschaft
viele wo man den kontakt
nach jedem passieren dass er das auch
mal krank wird aber einfach war ist er
krank macht ist
überhaupt in kraft ist und ich finde es
furchtbar
für sie wenn sie das gefühl hätte hektar
lebt und die termine lebt also finde da
völlig
tragisch dass man ja mit dem gedanken
ihnen lebt
natürlich wirft das fragen auf zum
beispiel wie sich opfer rituale und
erinnere hier stattgefunden hat das
nennt sich false memory syndrom falsche
erinnerung wo suggeriert werden
[Musik]
was ich einfach nicht verstand und der
80er und 90er jahre hat das schmolke in
amerika kanada australien die sogenannte
diese technik panic immer behauptet
hätte dass individuelle masse kinder
sexuell missbraucht werde quasi im namen
des teufels und
das ganze verschwörungstheorie oder das
klageverfahren untersucht und weil kein
einziger keine bewiesen ja es gibt
sexuelle missbräuche als hinter es gibt
ein und will ihn jetzt ganz viel
schließlich hinter porno ring aber das
hängt mit satanistischen rituellen
missbrauchs tue und ich verstand einfach
nicht woher die verschwörungstheorie und
wieso mit tiefer zelle mit aller kraft
georg otto schmid er ist experte wenn
zum
sektor zum beispiel oder in
religionsfragen oder haltung so
verschwörungstheorie ist der
richtige new york scheuen
große und das tut mir natürlich sehr
leid so mit sicherheit und ich soll bis
gehöriger denn schlimm zu erträgen als
das kind plötzlich behauptet wird man
sehr geteilt von al assad an esther
gelobt worden und hätte ohne lange
schien der missbraucht und danach hinter
vertrieben dann zum superstar mégane als
dass man sie stehen vor und wir sind dem
hexer waren jederzeit für einen sex
verschrieben werden das verstauen ganze
nehmen das phänomen sich da abspielt im
internet bezeichnete mit der
missbrauchsdebatte ist ja dass jetzt
während colonia übersteigert waren wir
in der region an beweglich das haben wir
das und noch mal eine luft gehen dass
man nämlich die kinder nicht um
sexuellen missbrauch zu einem dortigen
blut abzapfen und wenn das plenum was
angeblich von ihren extra gesagt ich mag
wie es uns gefällt
jung galt also der täters im normal mit
der dämonisiert worden behaupte ich zum
teil denn auch das ganze sehen sondern
unsere tische reptil jeder ernte war
datt et seqq aber man hat gemerkt
die panik an noch niedriger als hanna
schlimmer sie machen ausnahme dramatik
gewinnt darauf was ich nicht wieso
offiziell geschickt was ist grund fiel
ein dass sich aber und
glaubensvorstellungen
das so sehen dass es der cern der
touristische glaube sie glauben an gott
zu glauben an sie glauben dass die im
kampf sind mit der hand und dass die
verein auf der erde so ihre blüten gott
gerichtet und wie ich da seine zeit als
hatten und wenn man das bild hätte musst
es dir natürlich audi und renger patzsch
ortschaften fans und die apokalypse mit
black metal team sommer laufen die
gegend kein würde gleich mächtig als
organismus hat also da muss man nach dem
mehr als das und dass man sich dem
zeugnis imaginäres durch den aus stürzte
auf das objekt des vermerks gemüse kreis
der richtig auf so genommen wie es die
medien verbreiten dass iris weltbild
bestätigt dass es war sagt das
atheistische starke truppe vom satan auf
deiner welt gibt das ist ein motiv und
anderen motiven hat therapeutinnen und
therapeuten sich so schuller lohan und
den auf der schiene sinkt und das ist ja
relativ wort festgestellt dass wenn miss
- finanz- und rom in lohn der vorab hand
dass sich bestimmte glaubens vorstellig
vertreten denn willst recht wenig mehr
bits bringen dass die glanzvorstellung
relativiert werden mehr ist jedenfalls
sicher dass das ist ein großes stück weg
jetzt trafen das war wo es schon vorm
interview quartett
machen wir jetzt eine liste büro
wie man das verhalten bei dem treffen
weil es ist schon sehr
gefährlich
die schweiz spielt im weltweiten
satanismus keine nebenrolle sondern ist
geradezu ein zentrum die ermittler sind
zum teil mittäter ich glaube nachdem
bricht siehst du und
unterwanderung des alten ist
[Musik]
es gibt kein amt in der schweiz mit der
meinung nicht 1 wo nicht unterwandert
ist kann sich klopp ist besser und
führte dörfler vom orient jeder für
satan sie versprachen sich durch der
verbände mit ihm und durch die briefwahl
sozialer das ne weile opfer versprachen
sie sich macht galt
insolvenzmasse regelmäßig erschienen der
jugendliche frauen
seltener mann und wo man braucht
schlacht mit mir reden kommunismus dass
sie noch nach inter wo in den internet
kreis immer durch schwierige frage
und ich meine kamera stand auf haben
geburtstag und ich weiß aus dem land
damit abläuft ich muss wenn die da kann
ich das auch nicht der alleinige macht
muss ich ja hallo erst der zweite täter
wird noch verhandelt das ist ein loch 3
was macht also wieder etwa die rituelle
afrika von vollzogen das ist so hoch
dass blut vergossen wird und so das
mussten wir auch noch nie so richtig
problem ist die da der zinsen 88 steckt
zweite sich in lebensgefahr das islam
geführt
das grundstück
ist
die sogenannte dreckige spirale wo sich
sein pflichtet das symbol für pädophilie
und was hätte dass der ofen
das wollte ich mir standen
man fahre jetzt einen tatort und
satanisches und betriebe wenn wir den
abstoß erzähl ich glaube
wichtig ist also sagen hat falls darauf
hin dass autistische region statt auf
der burg auf der hochsee unter der 100er
oder unter dem see sei dass unter der
burg gegangen sie stehen gut das
funktioniert welche drs auf der klägerin
das stimmt dass wir meinen auch mit mini
da sind darin die wahl ist auch gar
nicht einfach aufmachen und galopp
das übergangen nicht das müssen wir
offen ist
ja eigentlich ist ein scheiß und mitten
in der serie passiert ist nein nein
hinter der tür verbirgt sich der
problematik es ist jetzt wirklich
die surfer und da sitzen sie vor allem
gestellt denn geriet so ist das nein
nein ich kann die kirche dazu das weiß
nicht
was ich mehr vermutet es mir auch gehört
warte permanent auswirkt wird
gelegentlich stand das installieren was
hans meiser jungen diebe dort hören
er hat aber jetzt da wirklich so anders
es ist also kein element vor dem
verschwörungs glaube es gibt kein zufall
also stückes paranoid waldbild man wird
verfolgt man hat immer eine ausrede
warum haben wir bewiesen und das gefühl
irgendwie steckt die mächtige mit unter
der decke der ksc hat ermittlungsbehörde
polizei oder so aus der literatur wird
unter dem ruf decken und dann bedanke
mich schmunzeln über das aber es ist
eigentlich überhaupt nicht zum lachen
bis man sowie dem weltbild muss
wahnsinnig viel im hintergrund vor der
radikalisierung passiert sind jetzt
trafen wir sagen kuhlmann dass alle
mobilen kuhlmann ist eu-politiker und
wer ruft falle dass er es immer dass wir
uns laden die rituelle satanische
missbrauch
und steht quasi ein fachmann
peter homann klar
das geht leider trauen schweiz gibt es
maschinen nach mindestens musik opfer
musiker beladen die von rituellen quad
obwohl das wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr
dürfte die dunkelziffer gibt und viele
opfer sich das selber noch gar nicht
bewusst siebels in der masse ab
gespaltene persönlichkeit die sogenannte
die sozia tief identitätsstörung wo vor
der tat der krise bewusst verursacht
wird im führen sollte im babyalter zum
teil um genauer besonders verhinderten
dass das auch passiert mentschow die
sozia tief identität steht haye werden
häufig als verrückt warnung für die
gesellschaft drum band gebucht sehr sehr
viel aufklärungsarbeit
die gesellschaft wird polizei wie auch
für beratungsstellen die psychiatrie
psychologie
und was sie dabei wenn damit
dissoziativen persönlichkeitsstörung das
ist wirklich absolut perfekt
dass man wirklich das krankheitsbild was
gibt
instrumentalisiert zum die
verschwörungstheorie verbreiten und
damit angst machen und das machen
jugendliche wachsen
das gebrochene hand dass man sie
eigentlich nur zu setzen salat und ihnen
erzählt und ich stimme missbraucht wurde
sie haben extra die krankheit verpasst
ziemlich dummes besuchen das ist absolut
profit moralisch unglaublich
veröffentlicht und sieht man dass die
erlitt wurde ist der nächste
verschwörungstheorie glaube eigentlich
selber ausmachen wo sie warnt bekämpfen
hat das tatsächlich sie das so ein
bisschen der psychotherapie passiert das
opfer quasi re dramatisiert werden mit
der geschichte von satanisten tochter
frauke ist jede drama station mit
therapie gegangen der umgang mit ihm
gelungen was geht eigentlich logisch
und sie sind journalist genau ok genau
und wir recherchieren gelangen dieser
geschichte gibt es das tatsächlich oder
sind das erinnerung wie ein patient zum
beispiel beschreibt wie er das erlebt
hat also oder ist gibt es das
tatsächlich in der schwarz nach dem was
wir von der schweiz aber auch
international wissen gibt es das also es
gibt aktuell organisiert
sozialistischer ja die sprache ja mein
größter lehrer ist kein buch kein
kongress und mein größter lehrer sind
die betroffenen
ich bin mit sehr vielen therapeuten in
kontakt auch international in kontakt
und da fällt auf dass diese schilderung
absolut zusammen passen dass das
organisierte strukturen sind und die
auch sehr genau wissen was sie tun
was machen die ja so was passiert da
dass man sich das vorstellen da sieht
das ja auch
senden wir ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
es passieren
unvorstellbare gewalttaten mit
körperlicher gewalt und körperliche
verletzung mit allen nur vorstellbaren
instrumenten das was wir auch so aus dem
dritten reich als foltermethoden in den
konzentrationslagern kann mit alles dort
angewendet wie eine parallelwelt
die extrem gut sich extrem gut zu
schützen weiß so dass es sehr schwierig
ist dieser menschen habe kraft zu werden
denn ist es auch schwer dass wir einen
therapeuten das zu entdecken
das ist schwierig durch sinn macht man
das dass sie fällt das manchen gar nicht
auf dass jemand in die weite guckt oder
keinen augenkontakt aufnimmt da sind
meistens nur ganz kleine zeichen wo es
erst mal wichtig ist dass ich die in
einem erstgespräch überhaupt wahrnehmen
und wenn es dann zu mehreren gesprächen
kommt und ich merke jemand ist immer mal
wieder nicht ansprechbar dass ich dann
nicht sagen ja das ist jemand der hat
einfach keine lust oder mal wieder
jemand unmotiviertes sondern ich frage
nach was ist bei ihnen los warum sind
sie immer wieder nicht ansprechen und
dann kann es durchaus passieren dass ich
dann etwas entdecke was überhaupt nicht
mehr zu der bisherigen depression
borderline störung oder den dergleichen
passt sondern eine völlig andere
richtung geht ob wir reden darf ich auf
einem level das unvorstellbar ist ja wir
reden da von menschenopfern blut trinken
aber ich schon mal gehört also wirklich
alle grausamkeiten die menschen ersinnen
können
finden dort statt
vielen dank glaube ich es auch für sie
es ist schwierig zu verarbeiten
und das was ich ihnen gerne empfehlen
möchte ist das was wir auch tun
das was jetzt in jeden tobt
auszusprechen und denn das sind ganz
ganz heftige dinge
das stimmt
das müssen wir machen
was machen
stimmung nichts dafür kann lassen
ich bin halt
ein ganz tolles
da bin ich sprachlos wenn man weiß aus
der kritischer forschung zu seinem
phänomenta satanistische ritual
missbrauchsgeschichte das genau die art
von therapeuten wo so felsenfest von dem
überzeugt sind so lächerlich was töne an
dass sie eigentlich lüth sind wo deine
wurden alle personen die idee überhaupt
erst vermittelt und nach ausgaben anders
sagen wann man besorgt eine therapie
gratis twitter zum opfer
er war ein charakter ritueller blues ist
eigentlich das hilfesystem für die
angebliche opfer von ritueller gewalt
wir sind auf dem weg zur oberen wo
ehrenamtlich für den verein kara lüth im
alter von 40 bis 50 begleitet
ich weiß ja dass die liga ihren
mentor wo ihre verzehr das
authentischste geht was in sachen machen
die renntage standen sie meint das macht
er bis kurz aber trotzdem
immer man sich hier wieder endlich stück
theater der herr kollmann
das sind
für mich gesetzt dass sie zum beispiel
am
wochende aroma oder sms wie irgendwo
ebay sidonie werde verfolgt
einfach das nicht mache ich es ich kann
es sich um vierte aber das kann ich zum
beispiel in honig hat die person monika
weihnachten übergriffe
ja unbedingt
der psychologe schnitt da wir haben vor
halloween irgendwie alles komplettere
drei
sondern den missen
mehr will er ja ich springe ich habe zu
spät gemacht
beratung psychotraumatologie und hg
gemacht war aber wirklich greift person
weniger im sinn zum jahr mehr sicher
boni mache sie glauben betrieb stellt
also mache das auf freiwilliger basis
geworden
die grossbay gratis daher stellt daher
genau das ist glaub ihre haupt musik
sehr groß
also ja sie wissen was sie machen vor
dem herrn schon immer
lehrerweiterbildung im rahmen woonio
über rituelles beruf klare
gedanklich um es milde formuliert
habe zum richtigen fleck aber sie ist
klar ich genau so wie sie jetzt
beschrieben hatte wo die falsche
vorstellung eigentlich noch
weiter kultiviert sie weiter wachsen sie
wieder ermutigend und ihre begleitung
genau das wonach gut dort verstärkt und
klar war nur dass gehört also süßer sieg
oder wer kennt missbraucht und so
schlimm war es einmal zu ja das machen
danke also ich glaube sehr viel auf der
emotionalen ebene ist auf die durch
favorisierte tja ist opferhilfe punkt ch
und dort sehe ich eine frau geschafft
für castagna das opfer hilfe für
sexuellen missbrauch also der opfer
hilfsstellen vom kanton zürich und die
psychiaterin die seite selber opfer
fußfessel aleker damit man sie 24
stunden am tag überwacht
stellen was man wo diese elektronische
überwachung von opfern so zu nutzen dass
immer klar ist wo die sind und wenn die
durch täterinnen täter aufgegriffen
würden dass dann das bemerkt würde und
im möglicherweise sogar eher
eingegriffen werden könnte
zu der resolution
gibt's das in der schweiz das ist ja
eigentlich
unvorstellbar die satanische rituelle
missbrauch kids was sagt dann ist das
interview die realität ich dir das sehr
sehr sehr viel manche vor genau den
erfolg wald wo sie so lecker lecker im
frühen kindesalter
erzählt
traumafolgestörungen antwort auf die
wiese dass die erst einige stimmen und
sie nahm aber dass das auch das neue
bistro dass das stimmt ich habe kein
foul oder jene schilder jetzt wieviel
dass dirk und werdet das ist einige
bricht sogar vor menschlicher weser wo
gefällt werden die hat natürlich ein
bisschen manche machten zahlen also sich
nicht unbedingt die unterschiede
gesellschaft statt man muss sie das
schweizer
besonders schwere
mannschaften befinden
18 was ist großstädtisch nicht wenig
wenn sie es hunderte von verletzten
bietet ihm sexueller missbrauch
mini erste wo dann irgendwie
gefragt das haben sie dann ja schon
abgeschrieben
also dass immer mehr gefragt und wo ich
dann seid ihr ja da seine show ab so hat
sie sich gehabt und am schluss im tor
sowie dem rituellen ist und wo
die
tägliche personen masken akh
ausführte hat wo ihre hartz verbrannt
worden ist dem für also wirklich so ganz
ganz ergriffen geschichten erzählt aber
das ist erst gemerkt hat dass ich mich
verlieben können dem thema
natürlich nach und einmaleinnahmen über
und dann können halt immer mehr manchmal
so eine thematik kann sowohl die
beratung stärker seine wm in der praxis
was ich natürlich auch mit jetzt viele
jahre darüber zu reden will damit sind
sie ganz schnell der fachwart so gut ich
bin gleich als fachperson
[Musik]
komische verein kara mache und am
schluss immer mit innerer verspricht
geschichte landet
polizei politik die psychiatrie und ich
meine dass es falsch erinnere gibt eine
therapeutische sättigen das ist ja
bekannt aber scheinbar ist das nicht
bewusst
die leute einfach konfrontiere ich muss
die frage ob es ihnen bewusst ist dass
sie offensichtlich in einer
verschwörungstheorie oft sind
das haben jetzt macht ihr alle
protagonisten konfrontiert mit einer
recherche und bespannt bis jetzt
reagieren
geschrieben haben aber dann ist völlig
da wichtig dass die jungs sagt dass man
die auf ihnen gehört oder nach
einzelfall schließe merian nicht uns
dass es einzelfall gibt
es ist ein ganz wichtiges feld nieder
verschwörungstheorien seit greifen
schöniger celik und in gott vor allem
die organisiert direkt rallye quattro
vom cdu-politiker samuel kuhlmann und
betont nochmals dass es organisierte
sexuellen missbrauch gibt und dass
stritten rau in keiner form ab das
problem ist tatsächlich der überbau auf
dem satanismus im untergrund hotel ideen
welche vater in der hand hält und
kindesmissbrauch an blut musste runter
werde das geht's nicht ich glaube nicht
dass man menschen der micra schade dass
man einfach für sie da ist und das ist
wieder da sony machen die briefe für sie
da wenn sie es brauchen
ich bedaure sie begleitet ich brauche
die binde sie überhaupt möchte retten
die therapie immer heftiger wird sich
verständigen anfang der stadtpolizei
zürich wo er schrieb gewalt an kindern
egal ob es sich dabei um sexuelle oder
körperliche gewalt handelt ist ein
sogenanntes offizialdelikt
das heißt die polizei ist von amts wegen
verpflichtet die meldung
entgegenzunehmen und den sachverhalt so
gut wie möglich abzuklären ob
die de mail distanzierter thomas während
nicht von verschwörungs film
parallelwelten begeisterung dem ohne
vorkomme und distanziert sich an eben
vom buch das schweigen brechen wovor
experte als verschwörungs propaganda wie
stuft wird und jetzt ist in den experten
prophezeit dass sie in einer
verschwörungstheorie und kurz
darauf stellte stärker hoch wie die
gefahr
bezeichnet zu dem thema
ein experte ich glaube ich bin momentan
karin bin ich
immer einen gegenstand oder theologen
gründete der autorin regula schwager hat
bis zu redaktionsschluss nicht reagiert
sie hat aber unmittelbar nach dem
interview zeigt dass sie sich klar
distanziert vom verein kara und das ja
nicht mit ihnen im kontext genannt
werden der oberarzt matthias kollmann
kritisiert als beitrag so wie auch die
experten scharf trotzdem haben mira dem
interview fest weil mit ihm einig sind
das öffentliche interesse zu dem thema
größer ist zudem dritter offen zum thema
rituelles beruf ganze die reportage hat
mich mit genau aber mir ist wichtig dass
man anruft und auch durchaus helfen beim
anderen indem du das video times
kommentiert unter dem motto los wir sind
erst am anfang